d'après les remontées d'informations
depuis 2018 le taux de poursuite
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
de 95% en cas d'atteinte aux élus
lorsque l'infraction est caractérisée
qu'un auteur a été identifié 100% des
mises en cause poursuivables font
l'objet d'une réponse pénale notamment
92% sous la forme d'une poursuite de mon
tribunal correctionnel c'est 10 points
de plus
10 points de plus que pour les autres
victimes et à ce titre une peine de
prison a été prononcée dans
84% des condamnations
contre les auteurs qui ont visé un maire
et dans cette affaire particulière de
Saint-Brevin la justice locale de ce qui
m'a été remontée n'a pas été aux abonnés
accents aux abonnés absents je tiens à
vous en dire deux mots même si
naturellement l'enquête est toujours en
cours et qu'il m'est interdit de
commenter une enquête
qui est en cours mais
dès réceptions d'un courrier qui a été
adressé par le maire de Saint-Brévin à
la procureur de Nantes le 15 février
la procureur de Saint-Nazaire a informé
téléphoniquement le directeur de cabinet
du maire que cette affaire relevée de sa
compétence territoriale non pas de
Nantes mais Saint-Nazaire et sa collègue
de Nantes a envoyé dès le 21 février
2023 une lettre à Monsieur Moret
l'informant de la transmission de son
courrier au parquet de Saint-Nazaire
pour compétence selon la formule
consacrée à la suite de la transmission
du courrier par son homologue nantais la
procureur de la République de
Saint-Nazaire a adressé au maire un
courrier le 27 février 2023 faisant
savoir celui-ci sa décision d'ouvrir une
enquête confiée à la brigade de
recherche de Pornic enfin après
l'incendie criminel du 22 mars la
procureur de Saint-Nazaire a eu
personnellement le maire au téléphone et
à communiquer à ce dernier son numéro de
téléphone portable personnel ce dossier
est actuellement traité au pôle criminel
de Nantes avec toutes les capacités
d'investigation
n'ont-ils dispose et conformément à mes
instructions générales les parquets
locaux ont donc toujours été en contact
avec ce maire menacé et ils ont pris
très au sérieux c'est fait en ouvrant
immédiatement des enquêtes qui je
l'espère vont aboutir très prochainement